hey everybody welcome back to park
attacked it's been a while that I've set
that sentence I know and part of the
reason is also the reason that there's a
big continue button over here to be
honest I tried recording this scenario
at the start of this year and got a
couple of attempts in but just couldn't
really build something that I was happy
with
somehow I was just struggling with the
theme and the limited amount of land
that we have in this scenario then I got
a new pc and I got addicted to Planet
coaster so I also didn't record anything
in architect for a while but right now
I'm really feeling like playing Park
attacks again and I really want to
tackle the scenario at last let me just
click that real quick and yeah let's
quickly have a look at what the scenario
entails so we have a hotel on a remote
island wants you to develop some
amusement attractions on its property to
attract more guests local authorities
will allow you to buy up all the
remaining land on the island but at a
high cost and the scenario wants us to
own at least 3 000 tiles of land which
is a pretty unique objective up to this
point in the game and we also need to
get a profit from riots for at least
four thousand dollars now I think the
latter is going to be the actual
challenge for this map I'm gonna forget
about reaching the non-optional goals by
the end of December year three because I
already know I'm not going to get there
and yeah let's quickly take a look at
the scenario and see why this thing is
so challenging at least challenging to
make a decent Park out of that I've been
struggling so much so we start off with
this tiny tiny amount of land over here
surrounding this yeah whatever it is
Castle Hotel looking building and we
slowly have to develop this and use more
and more of the island and 3 000 tiles
is quite a bit so we're definitely gonna
have to expend a lot here but if I start
buying some land you might be able to
tell that stuff is gonna get decently
pricey if we buy more tiles so
um yeah that's something to keep in mind
anyway let's get started oh before I get
started though one more fun fact that I
want to tell about this scenario and
that's actually going to come into the
gameplay here today this scenario is
based on woohoo Island from Wii sports
resorts and also some of the Mario Kart
games and you might have been able to
recognize that it has the same kind of
layouts with this mountain the the
castle looking building here and then
the lake ish area here with the bridge
everything's very similar just one thing
is missing that woohoo island has which
is a town so the way that I'm gonna try
and tackle it this time around is try
and recreate woohoo Island as much as I
can so most of the island is going to be
themed very lightly and just going to
use rides and stuff like that to fill it
all in but for part of the island I'm
gonna try to build a victorian-ish town
or at least something that kind of
resembles the architecture from Island
and I think Mario Kart is the best
example to go from so yeah that's going
to be my little experiment this time
around now let's get started hey
everybody it's over at from a few weeks
later in here and I am watching back
that intro and wondering why I was so
low on energy when I was recording that
don't know what it was but there was so
much vocal fry in my voice also you
could hear me breathing and I realized
I'm unable to try and filter that out
because I recorded my own audio and the
in-game audio to a single audio track so
you guys are gonna have to deal with
that and you're gonna have to deal with
realizing that you can hear my breath I
don't know if you guys mind that or if
you like listening to Muse I guess it
would be fine anyway but yeah I I don't
know sometimes you watch back yourself
and kind of cringe at it a little bit
but you know that's that's also part of
life anyway I should just
talk about what I'm supposed to talk
about here I'm starting off with a
roller coaster naturally because I need
something that makes money and that is
really the primary function of this
thing here because there's no way that
I'm ever going to be able to do anything
with this scenario if I don't at least
start off with a single attraction that
can single-handedly carry me throughout
this entire scenario because it's gonna
be quite difficult to build many roller
coasters from the get-go given the kind
of layouts that I want to give this
island and where I want to start
developing because this island is based
on wuhu island from Wii Sports Resort
and different Nintendo games as well and
there have been many variations of this
island throughout the times but that's
what it's based on and that's the theme
that I want to go for for this build as
well and to give a bit more detail about
some of the attempts I've done before
the first time I tried this scenario is
when I built this layout this roller
coaster that you can see me build right
now so it's basically just a recreation
but the first time I tried this scenario
I was going for a vaguely Victorian
theme with lots of wooden Pavilions and
decorated buildings uh kind of I don't
know resembling
architect builds it doesn't really
remind me of much else than just park
Tech builds there's lots of pillars and
roofs covering stuff and trying to
decorate it as much as possible it had a
kind of cool look but I didn't really
know what to do with that theme for some
reason it just didn't really work out
but you guys are gonna see some of the
remnants from that attempt in later
stages in this final and hopefully
successful attempt as well then the
second attempt I was going for a more
rustic unpainted wooden aesthetic which
was nice I guess but very similar to
what I've done in park Tech so far and
it just didn't really feel right to do
that on this island so right now this
third attempt I'm going to try and go
for
woohoo Island basically as a theme I'm
gonna try and make this look like a
beach resort tropical Vibes kind of
place slightly inspired by wuhu Island
but maybe also a little bit of Delfino
Plaza some Second Empire French Colonial
Mediterranean architecture inspired
stuff with the Victorian touches
that sounds like a a handful and like
way too many things at once but
basically something that seems tropical
and beachy and we'll see how we get
there but that's what my uh my new
attempt is going to be now one thing
that messed up the earlier attempts is
that I tried to make the station for
this coaster way too big I used to have
the uh the exit and entrance on either
side of the station and the queue would
wind down the hill just like it does
right now but it would take much more
space and it would just be housed in
this enormous building and it looked out
of place every time so on this attempt I
have the exit and the entrance on the
same side and the queue kind of winds
around the station building the station
building itself is only half the size
maybe less than half the size of my
previous attempts maybe I should just
stick some pictures up here so you can
get an idea of the iterations that this
park went through so yeah you can
probably see some random pictures pop up
right now but um yeah I think it just
works out a lot better the way that it's
uh it's it's shaping up now but keeping
that coaster layout it's pretty much
exactly the same as my previous tries I
think I ended up slightly adjusting it
yeah especially right here because the
roof of the station just needed a little
bit more space so I I adjusted that a
little bit I think the final Hill is a
bit different everything just happens to
be a little bit better I guess every
time you try and do something again
um so yeah there are some small changes
there but it's mostly on the station and
this layout just works out really well
because it doesn't need too much space
it's very easy to build it even has that
element over the water which I think is
a pretty cool interaction with also the
the pathways over there but at the same
time it's a very good money maker people
like to pay about eight to nine euros
for this thing and it doesn't have the
best capacity I could technically run
longer train on it but I think 12 card
trains just look very weird on this
coaster especially because it makes the
train so long but the movements that
this coaster makes are very sudden and
and very quick and kind of I don't know
how to say it but you know it's it's it
has a very small scale so a long train
would cause the back of the train to be
absolutely whipped over some of the
airtime Hills which funnily enough is
what happens on this coaster type in
real life I've never had the pleasure to
ride one of these things but Wally B
Holland is going to build one in 2024 I
believe so I'm super hyped about that
but yeah these things are known to have
pretty long trains in comparison to how
tight their elements are so you
apparently are supposed to get some
Wicked Air Time on these in real life
and I suppose this one in the game right
here is no exception that said all the
ones that are built in real life so far
all have a lift Hill and obviously I
don't have space to build a lift Hill
over here so a launch coaster it is and
I think it also makes sense because it's
a little bit more typical for launch
coasters to have very short layouts
obviously this layout is not much we
basically have all of five elements I
guess if we're generous
to be completely honest I still forget
what an immelman and a dive Loop is I
think at this point the dive Loop is
when you do a half Loop first and then
you do the corkscrew but it could be the
other way around but yeah we start off
with a dive Loop slash Eminem into a
quick turnaround into another dive Loop
slash moment except it's the other
element this time people in the comments
can definitely educate me on which is
which uh 10 years of being a coaster
enthusiasts and I still don't know this
stuff it's just I don't know it's like
it's like the roller coaster version of
left and right except I do know what
left and right is but you know plenty of
adults don't know what left and right is
all the time
um like sometimes I just forget what a
dive Loop is in an air woman and after
that we have that crazy kind of top hat
airtime Hill which is gonna
pull some gnarly negative G's I think in
the back and then followed by a small
Bunny Hop a helix over the water which
is going to be our fun interaction over
there I just realized while looking at
this and doing my commentary I really
missed an opportunity here to put some
water fountains at the in the Helix and
do that Mentor thing where the train
passes by and The Fountains activate and
it looks really cool definitely gonna
have to do that it's one of those things
in park Tech which I always forget you
can do in the game but it's such a cool
effect and you can be really precise
with the timing and the placement of
those things which is especially cool so
I should really do something with that
now we are moving into some other
sections of the park and I'm finally
gonna start building some buildings so
as you can see I already built my first
little building which is going to be
well which which was I should say my
little test building to see how this
theme is going to work and what kind of
pieces I can use for it obviously I've
already built the station and that was
pretty nice I'm pretty happy with it but
that's not going to be the architecture
that most of this park is going to have
now for the architecture of most of this
park I am generally inspired by French
architecture uh Second Empire slash
Queen and Colonial architecture that you
also find in the US which is
um most well known I would say for being
the Main Street architecture of
Disneyland very colorful it has those
typical roofs lots of arcades on the
ground floor and nice windows and
um nice windows that doesn't say
anything but a combination of classical
elements on the windows and and the
columns and stuff like that
um it's a little bit like Houseman
architecture in Paris I feel except on a
smaller scale a bit more colorful and a
bit more I don't know tropical fun theme
Parky so that's what I'm going for and
if I'm talking about this in very vague
terms it is because I don't have an
exact reference for this stuff now I uh
ended up not recording a section here so
I'm sorry about that guys I'm not going
to re-record that stuff but um it turned
out that my hard drive was full so I was
happily building stuff and then I
realized that I hadn't recorded a bunch
of things so now all of a sudden we have
these buildings there and as you can see
it has the sort of monster type roofs uh
columns with arcades on the ground floor
which lead to some of the toilets and
shop buildings and stuff like that and
then
um those those typical French I guess
normandy-esque chimneys as well that you
always see in those areas which I
haven't done enough of that in park Tech
but doing this really made me want to
try some kind of Normandy theme or maybe
even I don't know England I think it
could work very well with those large
chimneys that are separated or or that
are like right between every building in
a row of houses it just it's so easy to
do but it really has that typical look
and it's very fun to work on but uh yeah
that's basically our main city area for
now and I'm going to continue doing
buildings like that in the near future
but first we need to build another
Pavilion for one of these flat rides I
started off with the Pavilion of the
carousel which is a pavilion that I
pretty much recreated from my first try
of doing this scenario and it's one of
the few buildings which I actually
really liked from that try and figured I
should keep around and try and reuse and
for the Twister slash scrambled eggs
over here I was trying to come up with
something different to do because of
course every time I build one of these
Pavilions for a flat ride I'm trying to
come up with a structure that I haven't
done in the game so far because
otherwise everything's just going to
look way too similar and you're gonna
see me building the same buildings in
every episode plus it's just a lot more
fun to try and come up with new stuff so
this one's kind of all over the place it
was very fun to work on though because
it's kind of off-grid and many of the
pieces are half roof tiles or quarter
roof tiles and the Box 3D art shapes
just to be completely free form and try
and work with the smallest grid and make
something that's a little bit less
obviously on the grid and it results in
a building that is completely different
from anything I've done so far but which
I'm pretty happy with it's actually a
pretty cool I find and also that thing
is kind of hidden back in the woods
because my very idea for the layout of
the park is that around the lake we
really have the town developing and then
anything behind the buildings behind the
facades over here is kind of a little
bit more backstagey a little bit more
into the woods and I want to make this
whole island a little bit more wooded
um but yeah the scrambled eggs is the
start of that so it's kind of hidden
behind the tree line there and with
those trees I'm also trying to block the
view of the back side of those facades
as for the backsides of those buildings
I'm trying to not make them too much
like Disneyland backsides but like
realistic backsides of buildings because
something that I think is interesting is
obviously everything at Disney and
likewise many theme parks that built
main streets and the like is super thick
as soon as you look behind the facade
you realize that it's basically just a
warehouse building there's lots of HVAC
stuff on the roof it doesn't look
anything like it does from the front and
it's all all just fakery
and in real life this happens to some
extent as well and especially if you
look at French architecture anybody
who's ever been in a houseman style
building in Paris and Houseman style
buildings and are basically the type
that were built in the 19th century when
Paris was renovated on a huge scale and
these giant boulevards were created
through the city and the the typical
architecture that we now consider to be
Parisian uh was more or less invented
but if you ever go into one of these
buildings and look at the backsides uh
one of the windows at the back of the
building and look into the inner
Courtyards of these city blocks you'll
find that the the backsides are just so
ugly and messy and all over the place
and when I am trying to build my ugly
messy backsides of these buildings here
I was trying to do that real life ugly
backside messy stuff as opposed to the
Disney way of doing it so at the very
least these facades do have more or less
full roofs although there is a little
bit of gray flat roof structure in there
as well
um but if this were Disney and if you
look at Disney's Main Street you only
see so much of the building that you
really have to see and everything else
is just simple Warehouse stuff so the
fact that some of these some of these
roofs even go beyond uh just the facade
is already kind of
unrealistic for for being a Disney
inspired theme park building basically
so yeah that was my uh my little rant
about backstage all I'm saying is
I understand wanting to build your
backstage areas to be as ugly as
possible if you're building a theme park
but sometimes it isn't quite you know to
that extent and in real life there's
also a certain sense of facadism because
in real life you also don't have to make
the backside of your building as nice
looking as the front side which reminds
me also having lived in Brussels the
backsides of buildings in Brussels and
other Belgian cities to some extent as
well are especially ugly compared to
some of the fronts but also especially
interesting because you can find all of
these illegally created buildings that
are just glued to the backsides of of
the the nice looking fronts it's really
like that Simpsons meme where where
Homer is looking very proudly and you
can see his backside is whatever it is
in that Meme honestly I have no idea
um but now we get to a part where I
didn't forget or or where I I could
record because I finally realized that I
had to delete some files
so here's a bit of how I built some of
these buildings and the typical building
is is pretty straightforward we have a
ground floor with an arcade and some
arches lots of decorations of different
pillars and stuff then we have the the
second floor or the first floor I think
depending on whether you're an American
or a Brits but you know what I'm talking
about uh where usually I like to switch
to a different color as well so the
ground floor might be a little bit more
of a a darker color and have some
Granite textures or more Stone textures
and then once we get to the floor above
it we get some stucco walls or Sandstone
walls and a simple set of Windows maybe
some
um some flower boxes and some awnings
and then on top of that we have a mansar
roof which is that roof that starts out
steep and then gets gradually less steep
with some Dormers in it which is typical
Heisman inspired
but also a little bit Second Empire I
feel
so that's uh that's the building over
there with the the Red Roof and it's
basically following the same kind of
template that some of the other
buildings in this row are following
I also built that flat ride I originally
was thinking of building a pier there
but then I realized when I built the
pier out into the sea it didn't really
make any sense to have a pier that's
only about 20 centimeters above sea
level uh so I decided to just make it
look like that flat ride was built out
on the beach and we just have this
Plateau extending from the beach uh to
put that flat right there
um
but my dreams of building a pier at some
point I don't know if they're still
gonna happen uh definitely not over here
because I realized it just didn't really
work out with the layout of this whole
Space
also we have a section here where the
walkway starts to be raised up a little
bit and we get to this higher section so
we can look down on the beach I figured
that would look a little bit better plus
we end up getting some uh height
difference within the park which is
always interesting it's always nice to
have stuff kind of going over each other
and having different levels just make
stuff look nicer
um so I don't know if I would give that
as a general tip when doing scenery but
it it basically always holds true same
goes for the front of this building I
somehow wanted this building to function
as a way to get the pathway from the
Twister to come back to the boulevard
over here plus this gives the building
an actual function because I didn't want
to just have a row of empty facades but
there is a little bit of height
difference I have to make up over there
as well but I think it actually just
kind of works out in my favor because we
get this interesting part of the
building that shuts out and has some
staircases coming out of it and yeah I
think it makes for an interesting loop
around this area here the only thing
that I'm struggling with so far and I
still haven't really found a good
solution to is the fact that the rest of
this area doesn't really lend itself
very well for another flat ride or
roller coaster to be built it's just not
quite enough space to do anything
substantial with it but it's at the same
time I I it's an occasion where I do
want to do something with it because
otherwise it's just going to be Pathways
leading to nothing
[Music]
um but you know I'm I'm still going to
figure out what I'm going to do with it
because in the end it's not really a
nothing space either because I guess
there are some nice buildings over here
and it does lead to the beach which you
know and even though people in park
attacks are not going to be able to do
anything with the beach in my own mind
this is still where I don't know people
could hang out or something like the
very theme of this is to be a beach
resort town so obviously the whole
architecture and layout of this place
should try to follow that as much as
possible so hence also why I am putting
all of these uh fancy facades directly
facing the beach I might be pointing out
the obvious here but it's just a typical
layout for a beach resort town to have a
beautiful walkways along the beach with
fancy architecture and as soon as you go
anywhere beyond that
um you start getting into the into
Homer's back basically and finally for
this row of houses I decided it's time
for a corner building I love Corner
buildings they're just so much fun and
they're always the it's always nice when
the corner building is just that little
bit more fancy than the other buildings
you can't have too many Corner buildings
obviously but when you do every now and
then you got to put you got you have to
put Aspire on that thing or a little
Dome some extra decorations and it's
always fun so this one I'm giving this
one a dark blue roof because I figured I
didn't really have enough blue of this
shade yet I'm trying to keep all of the
buildings very colorful and this I took
from wuhu Island because wuhu island has
all of these colored roofs especially a
lot of blue and orange so I'm definitely
copying that a little bit so that when
you zoom out from this map and swing
your eyes a little bit it does kind of
resemble woohoo island or at least I I
could I could tell people you know
that's inspired by Wu Island and people
could be like ah yeah I kind of see it
at least I hope that's that's the case
um but yeah that's uh that's our little
corner building over here
didn't really know exactly what to do
with this in terms of shape but now that
I'm looking back at this thing I'm
actually quite happy with the textures
most of the walls are from the adventure
set the South American Temple pieces
basically and then we have Aspire with
an extra little blue pointy bit up top
which is something I haven't tried with
this roof Spire piece but I think it
works very well actually and the same
goes for that little fence that goes
alongside the roof it's a little touch
but it just helps make the building feel
that little bit more late 90th Century
which also reminds me that in the late
90th Century there were a lot of beach
towns with this kind of architecture in
Europe something that comes to my mind
is ostenda in Belgium which used to have
a lot of this kind of Victorian
architecture
and uh most of it is now gone in favor
of Giant's concrete skyscrapers that's
not relevant to the video at all
um but sometimes I do find it very
inspirational to look back at old
pictures of ostenda I also don't want to
turn this into a hate speech about
ostenda because that City gets way more
than enough hate it's actually a pretty
fun city it's got a nice Beach and it's
well worth the visit if you're ever
around Belgium for an extended period of
time and you're thinking of going to the
beach it's pretty cool so uh honestly
I'd recommend it speaking of the beach I
figured I couldn't leave this beach on
uninhabited well it's it's unbeached on
like like someone it last it has to look
like people can actually go to the beach
on this beach if you know what I mean so
I decided to put some parasols in here
and make some uh well I'm still trying
to come up with these things but you
know what what they are exactly but they
are the kind of thing that you can you
can lie down on the beach on so um yeah
that's uh what the 3D art pieces are
pretty useful for
and with that said I think I've been uh
doing this time-lapse for long enough
it's time to take a quick look into the
game and see how the Park's doing I
think
all right so here we are our Beach town
is taking shape and it looks like the
park is healthy financially so that's
pretty good we can actually continue in
this scenario it's interesting how
normally I feel these scenarios because
I end up in money troubles but at least
that's not the issue this time around so
here's my facade of buildings that I
didn't record it's not too interesting
honestly I don't think you guys missed
out on too much but overall I'm pretty
happy with how the boulevard ends up
looking and especially on the back side
as well I was a little bit nervous on
how this should work given that building
buildings like these really tends to
create some backsides and I had to
figure out how to sufficiently hide them
in a sense that wasn't too Disney like
or too much like there's one big Bland
block of buildings because I figured it
wouldn't really look right with the
layout of this park but I'm pretty happy
with this especially I have some of the
trees end up hiding it and we have the
sort of hidden scrambled eggs over here
I still need to figure out what I'm
going to do with this corner but I'm
pretty happy with the corner building
itself so even this I think is going to
be a good blueprint for the other side
my plan is to have more buildings over
here maybe even a whole city block and
really make this feel like there's a
town and then the rest of the park map
can be much more sparse and have some
roller coasters here and there and for
that reason I might want to
um develop into this area before I start
working on the town here because truth
be told the town area is not going to be
to profit making because there's just
not that much in terms of roller
coasters that you can build through a
town like that I think it would be
really cool but I think it's just not
really going to work with the scenery so
I'm gonna try and build my roller
coasters and stuff like that over here
give this more of a foresty woodsy Vibe
and maybe see if we can get some
interaction between like a mine train
and a log flume or stuff like that and
then we'll get to all the shops and flat
rides in the city area over here and
basically this is going to be woohoo
City I guess I don't know if the city
actually has a name but in the real
woohoo Island this is right about where
this city would be but then again the
lighthouse would be over here and maybe
if this was Wii Sports we'd have some
stadiums here and there
um I'm I'm taking a lot of uh the
creative liberties with that one but
it's it's still a general inspiration
um I just realized I need to do a quick
POV of this coaster because I feel like
I'm obliged to give you guys that so
let's
go ahead and see what this thing rides
like it's a little bit too short and I
was thinking of maybe extending this
coaster once I have more money and I
don't need to worry too much about the
layout but also I don't know I think
it's I think it's fine like this
especially for a launch coaster so we
start off with that a moment dive Loop
kind of thing still not entirely sure
um I think this transition actually
works out fairly well given that I
changed it a little bit later to fit the
station roof under it and then down to
the water where we build up some nice
speed and maybe even hit the top speed
of the ride I'm not sure and back into
the station with quite a bit of speed
but you know with coasters like these
I'm pretty sure the electromagnetic
brakes can recharge the launching system
or something along those lines shouldn't
be too much of an issue
um but yeah it's pretty cheap I think it
looks alright and it manages to make a
decent amount of money although
seemingly less So lately not sure why
that is
also
this thing is not that intense but oh
there it's okay sure I'll lower the
price a little bit I've noticed that I
started off with ten dollars for this
ride then I turned it into nine then it
became eight and now that this thing's
eight years old I guess people don't
want to pay for it anymore so yeah it's
time to build some new roller coasters
we've we've had this thing for too long
it's really time to expand so we'll see
what I can do over here maybe even an
Alpine Coaster I rarely did one of these
things and also I don't think I've built
a single steeple chase in any scenario
yet so I'm gonna try and think of a way
that I can incorporate one of those as
well but honestly I have no idea either
I just press record and see what happens
so without further Ado let's do that
all right now this is the point in
recording and editing where I realize
that this is going to be the longest
video in the history of my channel so
that's quite something I have to say the
way that I make these videos is usually
I record a real-time section then I
record a time lapse then I record the
commentary for that then I go back into
the real time section and then I start
doing another time lapse with commentary
hence why especially with how long these
videos take all of the different audio
takes that you'll find of me throughout
this video are multiple weeks apart uh
so I'm a whole different person at this
point yet again from the silverette that
you just heard a few seconds ago so
that's that's fun I guess and I think
it's not completely unusual for YouTube
videos to be made like that but with
this episode in particular it's gonna be
a bit of a challenge to see how well I
can stick to the format because truth be
told I'm I like to think I'm pretty good
at talking without actually saying
anything and try trying to keep talking
while getting little to no input of what
to talk about and I like to go on Long
Rambles and tensions and stuff like that
but I am sitting here in front of my
editing software looking at an hour of
time lapse footage thinking
this isn't even all of the time lapse
that I've recorded and I already forgot
to record some parts and there are some
parts where my hard drive was full and I
had to wipe some other stuff to make
space for this
extremely large episode and I'm still
thinking God this is this is just too
much I'm not sure how I'm going to keep
this up but that's enough meta
commentary for now I'm gonna try to not
start off every time lapse with a bunch
of meta Insight that you guys may or may
not be wanting to get
um I'm starting off this part of the
park with a large Boulevard next to the
water and the idea for this section is
that this is going to be really the main
section of the town so I'm going to put
most of the buildings here lots of flat
rides a very Carnival Beach Town esque
vibe in general and mostly the theming
and the pathway structures and stuff
like that I'm going to keep around from
the rest of the map which to be honest
is something that you might have noticed
is something thing that I like to do in
general usually my first couple of
buildings but also my first couple of
paths and all of the scenery around it
the tree selection and stuff like that
as well all of that at the beginning of
a scenario is kind of my trial run to
see how everything Vibes together and to
get my color palettes and textures and
different things and pieces that I'm
using and then once I get into the
latest the later section of making the
scenario I just copy those colors and
items throughout the map to try and get
a cohesive look throughout the entire
map and that's basically what I'm doing
here as well taking some of the same
path textures and ways that I've made
the Beach Boulevard on the other side of
the water and kind of transplanting them
over here some fun little tidbits that
are uh interesting to talk about I think
are the use of The Pavilions over the
queue line over here it's something that
I don't remember where I saw this but
somewhere on the park attack Discord
which uh by the way is a really great
source to look for inspiration and
fellow architect players
but somewhere over there I found this
interesting technique of putting
different Pavilions inside of each other
the one with the the shade sale
basically and rotating them 180 degrees
and it creates this interesting
checkered pattern of rectangles and it's
really fun and really easy to do and
it's something that I don't think I've
ever used before and I haven't really
seen many people use it but it's a
really nice trick to create some
diversity over there as well so I
decided to give it a go with these
planes over here as for the planes
themselves
generally I feel like there are flat
rides that you can put in buildings and
put a roof over and there are flat rides
where you can't really do that these
planes I think are kind of in the middle
ground where the middle section is a
little bit too tall but it's still
doable to put it inside the building but
then that defeats the whole purpose of
having planes it wouldn't really fit the
theme to put this thing inside a
building and rather I feel like you
would want to have some open space so
either put those somewhere on a hill or
next to the water or something like that
the latter is what I ended up going for
in this scenario so
um yeah I'm going to be pretty careful
with where I place which flat rides
which is a voice crack also something
that is
um I don't know a little bit different
from my usual approach because usually I
like to build lots of roller coasters
and flat rides are just kind of the
filler but in this park I feel like flat
rides actually takes Center Stage to the
whole layout and the theme of the park
and I think it's just because flat rides
work a lot better in the beach people of
fire setting and don't destroy the urban
fabric of the town that I'm trying to
create here and trying to mesh roller
coasters together with lots of buildings
is something that's decently doable and
it's a lot of fun to do
um but then you get to Fantasia lent
levels of theming which I think is going
to be pretty hard to pull off in a
scenario setting
um Plus for flat rides you don't need
that much space so with flat rides I was
able to start expanding the park little
by little and adding extra rides which
also adds more guests and more profits
which makes it a little bit easier to
expand a bit more and roller coasters
once you get to the point where your
roller coasters end up becoming quite
large and have a decent footprint and
become pretty expensive I felt like they
were too big an investment to make at
this stage and I would rather try to
expand the park a little bit bit by bit
and try to increase my profits that way
up to the point where I have enough flat
rides that I can actually make a decent
bit of money from all of these flat
rides uh plus the extra guests that it
draws in increases the profit of the one
roller coaster that I do have and by
that time I can hopefully expand the
park in large sections that are actually
big enough and have given me enough
budgets to build some big proper roller
coasters
at least that's the plan plus I wanted
to start off with theming the water side
over here and making these boulevards
before I did anything else because I
felt like they are the most important
part of what I wanted to pull off here
and I can always move to the back
sections uphill at some later stage and
add some of the roller coasters over
there
so over here we have a toppling Tower I
believe these things are called
it's a it's a flat ride that I don't get
to use very often in scenarios and I
think part of the reason is that it has
such an enormous footprint and it's just
kind of awkward to get into certain
locations but looking at this island I
was thinking for a while of what's
placed in here and once I tried putting
this thing over here I realized that
it's pretty much the perfect setting
just like the planes you really want an
open space I feel like for these things
you want to put it on a make it a
centerpiece part of the theming and part
of the scenery and really showcase that
ride especially because it's it's so
wacky and so weird so I felt like this
island was actually the perfect place to
put this thing
um I think it's called a topple Tower
not a Top Lane Tower but yeah fun facts
about these things in real life I
believe there are only two of them ever
built at least the two that I know of
one in Belamar in Belgium which is still
standing today and one in your
Summerland in Denmark which has been
demolished and I've had the pleasure or
displeasure of riding the one in Denmark
and I have to say they are pretty fun I
think it's a very creative idea for a
flat ride that said if you're if you're
of the male sex and you have your male
genitals and you're a little bit on the
taller side it can definitely be a
slightly uncomfortable not horribly so
but definitely to the extent where
you're like I'm not entirely sure how
much I like this but I really like the
idea of these things they look really
fun off ride they're just really fun to
look at and
um the theming of the whole thing is
pretty cool as well this one doesn't
really have any theming but the one in
Beloit I believe as well also has that
bird's head on top of it and it just it
just looks so weird bopping up and down
and I think the the fun part of it as
well is
um the fact that it does a completely
opposite movement from what most flat
rides do in theme parks most flat rides
just spin in some sense and uh some flat
rides swing and then again some flat
rides also Spin and swing at the same
time these are generally the movements
that 99 of flat rides do and once you
you know sort of get that theme into
your head it's something that you can't
unsee as well because the variety of
flat rides is really not that big they
just all find different ways to spin and
swing and this thing does a completely
different motion than any other flat
ride and I think that's something that I
respected for it's creative idea the
engineering behind it is super
impressive
it just the right experience is is fun
because it's Unique but these were never
going to conquer the world so I think it
makes sense that these things were never
a huge success on the flat ride market
that said it's really fun and uh it's
not really fun but it is fun for what it
is for the novelty that it is and if you
ever find yourself with the opportunity
to visit bellavada in Belgium you should
definitely give this thing a try
um because they might very well be
extinct at some point in the future and
that would be kind of a shame and at
least it's good that these things are
forever in park attacked you know we'll
never forget about these things uh
unless it's me forgetting the name of
these things and calling them a toppling
Tower but you know what what does that
matter anyway
um now over here on the left I decided
to put my next flat ride which is the
spiral slide which has that typical
Helter Skelter old school look and fun
fact this is not not based on the roller
coaster tycoon spiral slide both of
these spiral slides are based on the
traditional helter skelter's lights that
you find very often in British
Fairgrounds and theme parks I believe
and it's just a classic look and I feel
like the look of the building itself is
really
even more special than the slide itself
because the slide is just a spiral slide
we've all been on slides you know it's
not it's nothing special but the
architecture of the building I think is
really nice really charming and what
makes these things so distinct
also it looks a little bit like a
lighthouse but of course this map
already has a lighthouse so there was no
use theming this thing to be a
lighthouse but I could very well see
using basic shapes in the game to turn
one of these spiral slides into a custom
Lighthouse I think what that would be
pretty fun to try
anyway at this point I figured it was
time for a roller coaster but I didn't
quite have the space nor the money to
build a big old roller coaster so I
wanted to go for something that I
believe I've never done in a scenario
before and which to my knowledge I think
I've actually never built in architect
before which is yeah one of these Arrow
horse riding coasters and
um
something that uh I found very cool but
at the same time kind of annoying about
these things in Architects is that they
are very accurate they are
very much based on their real-life
counterpart one of which is still
running in Blackpool pleasure beach in
England and I believe it's also the only
one uh still operating which is a
Steeplechase at some point there was a
similar version of that ride in Knott's
Berry Farm I believe it was but I'm not
entirely sure uh which was the the Derby
racers I believe it's called which is
also what the Soapbox Derby racer ride
in Roller Coaster Tycoon one was based
on
um we are just restricted to horse
vehicles on the coaster in the game but
yeah it's this single real coaster which
doesn't really hit any high speeds
whatsoever but I do believe this is
probably very thrilling in the sense
that you are very vulnerable because
you're sitting on top of a horse and the
the ground is quite a few meters below
you at that point and you're still
making a decent bit of speed so I I've
never written one of these things so
it's very difficult for me to figure out
what the right experience would be like
but there's one in Blackpool pleasure
bleach pleasure Beach actually I think
it's three or four tracks that are
dueling
um and also because these things
typically dual because they're they're
very much themed to doing that kind of
thing I first started off with a single
layout but then I figured nah it just it
does it just doesn't work for this kind
of coaster we really need two tracks
plus that means we have two coasters in
our attraction lineup which hopefully
means a few more guests and a little bit
more income and it's also more fun to
look at these things kind of dueling I
didn't do the dueling thing entirely
correctly because the blue track loses
most of the time not always if the red
track is empty the blue track usually
wins
um but red has a slight advantage that's
just how it is it was very difficult to
work with the space that we're given
here and we also don't have any breaks
or any other special elements on this
coaster in architect and the reason that
I said it's almost kind of too realistic
to the degree then it's a little bit
annoying is that you really can't add
any big drops to these coasters the lift
Hill can barely be a few meters tall
before it starts screaming that it's too
high for supports and yeah these things
just make it difficult to make any kind
of fun layout with these things plus I
still had to figure out where to put the
Q lines and the exits and have the
pathways go around this area as well
while at the same time having a decent
enough layout where the horse carriages
can can both kind of do their dueling
thing so um it was not actually as easy
to figure out this layout as I thought
it would be there's also the thing that
you don't want the curves to be taken at
too high of a speed because it would be
uncomfortable you can only Bank these
Corners uh 20 degrees
so we just have some curves then a dip
and then a little Hill again and then
another curve at a lower speed and then
some dips and that's basically it all
the way down to the station
um with a little bit of space to also
have some Pathways around this area but
yeah it's it's pretty fun to look at
also at this point the footage is
standing still for a while
um
because I was getting a call at that
point but yeah we're gonna continue a
fun fact that was definitely a five
minute call
um but looking back on time lapses it's
uh sped up about 12 times so everything
whizzes by
then there's the challenge of building a
station for these things especially
because the blue track is coming
dangerously close to where I was
planning to put the station building I
also went through a couple of roof
designs as you can see before I decided
to go for this hips roof over here as
you can see
um not really the best ever station
building but I really wanted to figure
out a way to make this work with the
layout of these coasters and yeah I
think it works out in the end plus I
wanted to use certain cornices that I
could put lights on which I feel I
haven't really talked about enough yet
but I really wanted to light up the park
everywhere so I put all of these little
light bulbs in typical Victorian fashion
as you often see with these kinds of
buildings everywhere which is honestly
pretty easy uh generally what I did is
to take the spherical light the one
that's pretty big but make it very small
and
um yeah just put it everywhere on uh the
fourth uh grid option so alt 4 gives you
that grid that's four times smaller than
the standard grid of the game and then I
just added those things everywhere
and now it's time for a flat ride inside
a building but in a different way than I
normally do these things so we're going
for the classic teacups this is one of
those flat rides that you generally
always want to put a roof over it just
works too well for that kind of thing
plus from a gameplay perspective and a
real life perspective as well it's
always good to have flat rides that are
covered for rainy days and that goes for
rides that are covered in general but
flat rides as well which is
um also very fun to put inside I was
visiting Europa Park two weeks ago and
Europa Park has this ride called
Columbus yolan which is a typical
Carousel that is usually reserved for
Kitty areas
um not a carousel with horses but the
one with boats that kind of go up and
down but this one is so good and I don't
want to spoil what it does just in case
any of you guys ever visit Europa Park
all I want to say uh do write Columbus
yolin it's all the way in the back in
the Spain area it doesn't look that
special it's next to a kitty's
playground and some other uh very much
children oriented flat rides and in fact
this flat ride is not very big it's not
super intense it's really a kid's ride
but it's just so good because it's
within it's inside a building and the
theming is amazing and it really puts on
a show so all that to say flat rides can
be really great if you put them indoors
and especially if you combine it with
some theming as well I feel like flat
rides in general in Real Life theme
parks but also in theme park games are
too often just reserved for filler to
put in different areas filler both in an
aesthetic sense in that they can fill
out an area and in a day filling sense
that flat rides are always fun to do in
between coasters and in between rides
that have very long queues but um yeah
themed flat rides and indoor flat rides
are the way to go very underrated and I
think Europa Park has one of the best
ones with Columbus yolan so definitely
give that one a try if you're ever in
the area and if there are any other
fellow Columbus yellow and fans out
there either I'd love to hear the
support for me it was one of the rides
that really positively surprised me also
because I went in with zero expectations
I was just dragged in there by my
traveling company who was like you have
to see this and I was like what is this
going to be I'm I was super skeptical
but it kind of blew me away but uh yeah
that's uh that's that so put your flat
rise in indoors is generally what I'd
say but I'm I've been getting very off
topic uh we're talking about teacups
here and the reason that I wanted to try
this thing a little bit differently is I
knew I wanted to build some big facades
over here some big French Beach tropical
colorful facades over here and I wanted
this whole area to look like a city
basically
but I wasn't really sure what to do with
those buildings I couldn't just put food
courts and toilets in every building but
also these kinds of buildings aren't
the most interesting for flat rides So
eventually I came up with this idea the
outside of the city block is basically
generic City Block buildings and the
same style as the buildings on the other
side of the water over here and then on
the inside we have this glass canopy
that covers the flat ride and where you
can see the back sides of some of the
buildings as well and some of the
chimneys sticking out and stuff like
that a little bit of the messy side and
the less decorated side of these
buildings as they typically tend to be
in real life too and yeah it allows
natural light to come into that flat
ride makes it feel like you're really in
the city but at the same time allows me
to give these buildings an actual
function and not just let them be a
scenery because I'm trying very hard to
not build buildings that don't have
functions anymore it's something that I
used to do a lot in theme park games for
many years just because I like buildings
and um
I'd like buildings building buildings
first before coming up with what they
actually should be doing there
um but I think this is actually a pretty
fun way to theme a flat right like this
plus if this were just covered with a
standard Pavilion I felt like at that
point we would be seeing way too many of
those typical obvious flat ride Pavilion
roof structures and it would just get a
little bit boring and repetitive at some
point
um speaking of which I am still trying
to keep the themes of these buildings on
the side very repetitive and taking a
lot of the colors and the building
elements from other buildings so what I
also noticed is that I was getting uh
much faster at building these buildings
than I was at the beginning because at
this point I'm not trying to figure out
any more what kind of pieces I'm going
to use and what colors I'm going to
select and everything's already obvious
before you start building a building
which in this case was pillars first and
then the connect between those pillars
with art pieces some arches or simple
walls at the ground floor and then
decorated windows that either go into
the building or stick out of the
building with different pieces and a
steep roof with lots of Dormers and
those typical chimneys on the sides and
then the way that you do all of these
details the specific pillar pieces that
you use the collars the the details
everything you try to vary those between
the buildings but the same style is
generally apparent everywhere so we have
two floors and then a roof a mansar roof
with Dormers of different styles and we
have one color for basically all of the
walls which is the Sandstone for all of
these buildings one color for the roof
and one color for the details like
mostly all of the awnings on these
buildings
which comes back to a very common trick
for theming like this which is that
every building should have three main
colors uh one for the walls one for the
accents and one for the roof and you can
vary a lot within those themes you can
basically choose whatever colors you
want and you think work out but as long
as you stick to those rules generally
all of your buildings are going to look
fine and obviously you can break these
rules because rules are always meant to
be broken and breaking the rules is
sometimes also what makes things fun and
interesting and engaging but these rules
are a really good guideline to get good
color schemes in general and then
there's also some some other rules that
you can apply to this uh like the fact
that walls should typically be very
mellow rustic colors not too eye-popping
not too bright or saturated and then X
hands can be the most saturated colors
and roofs are somewhere in between and
typically also a little bit darker than
the walls but those are some some extra
tips and tidbits but the three color
rule is something that is very good and
easy to follow and it's something that
you can very often see apply to real
life theme parks as well very obviously
on Main Street USA in Disneyland or
Disney World you can really see the the
walls the accents and the roof colors on
many of the buildings
anyway moving on the next thing that I
wanted to build over here is kind of a
centerpiece for the street it's the
train station
and yes I am going to build a train and
it's going to go all throughout this
island and it's going to connect this
side to the other side
partly just because I wanted to do
something like that it just felt like
the natural kind of thing to do since we
have such a large island and also
because I think it just adds a fun layer
of complexity to the whole park if you
have a train that goes over and under
some of the rides and Pathways
everything's just a little bit more
interesting once you have different
things Crossing each other
um which is why Taryn in Fantasia land
is so good okay I need to stop randomly
associative thinking the rambles
um but yeah that's uh that's that's
something that always works out you know
try to not make your Parks too flat try
to have lots of different interacting
with different things interacting with
each other on different layers uh yada
yada yada that is basically what results
in an interesting Park to look at
now for the roof of this building I used
some of those uh some of those yeah
mansar roof pieces again and I realized
that because of the shape of this roof I
had some weird little pieces sticking
out and decided to use that as a
strength instead of a weakness and just
added lots of different roof pieces in
the middle of the roof where you don't
see most of the of the roof piece but
you do see uh the bits that stick out
above the gray roof tiles or or roof
pieces on the on the roof there but
that's that's a stupid sentence but you
know what I mean so we get that sort of
great pattern of different uh golden
sections over there which I think uh
actually kind of kind of works it gives
this whole building an almost steampunky
steel Vibe but I believe that fits with
the train station
um given the fact that this is the kind
of typical train station architecture in
a just world I would have loved to give
this thing uh some some curved glass
a hallway look that some train stations
in real life do have but given that this
is architect and we don't have the
curved glass pieces that I was hoping
for alas it's something that is never
going to happen but I think this is a a
good uh second option as well plus we
have a dome in the middle which is that
kind of centerpiece element that you can
see in the distance as you're walking
through that Boulevard with the
buildings on the sides so I think it's a
good way to uh yeah
basically finish that whole city area
and don't worry about that block in the
middle
um it's going to be filled in at some
point in the future as well but for now
I first wanted to figure out some more
of the layouts of this whole area which
generally I feel much more comfortable
doing some of the scenery once I've
already figured out the layout of an
area it's kind of spooky and scary to
work out details in scenery before you
know how everything's going to be laid
out exactly so you'll often find me
especially in this scenario I think
because this was a very difficult map to
work with layout wise you'll often find
me just working out a general direction
of where to go and plopping down some
flat rides and paths before I move back
to all the areas and try to re-theme
those things
now for this part I'm trying to lay it
out in such a way that I can make use of
the terrain differences instead of
having it become a weakness of this
whole area and I think there are some
interesting ways to do that for one we
have the train station that also kind of
hides a staircase uh behind it and I
think what's fun about it is the fact
that the train station is elevated from
the perspective of the Main Street which
is pretty typical if you compare it to
many train stations in theme parks like
the entrance of Europa Park or of
Disneyland in Hong Kong but also I think
Disney World also has that one
um so we have that elevated train
station look but because it's on the
hillside the train reels themselves
actually stay on the ground the whole
time which is what I'm trying to do with
the train line in general you know I
don't want to build many big Bridges and
stuff like that I'm going to try to work
it into into the terrain so that the
rails are on the ground the whole time
and then behind the train station
building we have the staircase that
leads up the hillside so it's a it's an
interesting kind of way to hide how that
works but still have that elevated train
station look from the Main Street and
then over here the stone Plateau that I
Was preparing there is uh going to house
uh chair swing which hopefully given the
fact that it's on this Stone Plateau
that's kind of jutting out and has this
view over the rest of the city I say
City but you know it's it's basically a
very small fake town that I'm trying to
make look as much like a large town as
possible but yeah you'll have some views
over there and hopefully that location
of the flat ride is going to work out in
my favor as well
and then there's a of course some of the
detailing I wasn't really sure how to
detail these horse coasters exactly so I
just put some gardening around it I
think it fits in with the area around
the Helter Skelter too
um but it's nothing very remarkable or
super themed which also given the theme
of this park I don't think the coasters
really need that I feel like the the
beach resort theme is actually kind of a
meta theme that works for theme parks
very well because the fact that it's a
theme park is is kind of part of the
theme itself
uh which is which is always one of the
most clever themes I feel like but at
the same time one of the lamest I know
thanks to comments uh on my video where
I was critiquing philosopher uh that
velocity coaster is themed to being a
roller coaster uh philosopher is a
roller coaster in Universal Studios in
Orlando and the theming of that coaster
is that it is a coaster going through
the Velociraptor enclosures uh which is
a a pretty cool theme because it doesn't
really get more immersive than actually
being on a roller coaster so you know
props to them for coming up with that
with that idea uh stupid of me of not
realizing it before I was recording my
video but in my defense as much as I do
have many Theme Park facts and
experiences in my head I do these
recordings with very little preparation
and mostly just ramble whatever comes
out at the top of my head which isn't
always accurate so definitely do do
double check me and if you watch my
videos please do check the comments
because people are very Vigilant at
correcting me which I am very thankful
for because a stream of Consciousness
will never be completely correct and I
think this goes for streamers and
podcasts especially which are sometimes
just justly corrected on different facts
and critiqued for not being entirely uh
true but I think it's something that's
also part of the nature of just
recording free-flowing conversations and
monologues which is is very different
from scripted content I think which
should definitely strive to be more
accurate than just a free-flowing stream
of Consciousness content and I am not
going to do scripted content because
honestly it's already enough effort to
try and record videos like this at a
somewhat uh reasonable pace of uploads
the way that I'm doing it right now also
I have no idea how I would sound
scripted I feel like it would be very
different I feel like at least you do
get a little bit of my personality
coming through a little bit more in my
commentary even though obviously at any
point of the day and in our lives we all
have our masks that we put on and
especially as a content creator there's
a certain way that you talk and do
things that isn't exactly the way that
you would in a real life setting
um but yeah it still it feels a little
bit more personal I guess
anyway moving on we still have a lot of
time lapse to go we still have a lot of
work to do for the scenario the next
thing that I wanted to do is build a big
fancy building and I wasn't really sure
why I wanted to build a big fancy
building but I just knew I really wanted
to do it and uh this was going to be my
attempt at doing that
um generally when you get to big fancy
buildings in a classical or neoclassical
style that's just where you bring out
the extra details so instead of just one
pillar you have double pillars
everywhere double columns with more
detail and larger cornices and
everything so that's what this building
is about we have double pillars and
awnings and window boxes and all the
windows the windows are larger than some
of the other buildings windows we have
that big old front door and it's just
all around a good experience it's a lot
taller than the other buildings as well
because I needed all of that extra
height to make these cornices using the
basic art shapes
um but yeah this might be I don't know
some big office or bank or something
like that something that I am still
procrastinating on in this scenario but
do want to do at some point is putting
signs on some of these buildings and
maybe it's not the most uh smart maybe
it's not the smartest decision to do
that after I've already built all of
these buildings
um but yeah it is something that I am
very well aware of
I think this would look a little bit
better if there was a sign up front that
said hotel or
um bank or whatever maybe it's even a
grand hotel I think it could very well
be the Grand Hotel
um but it's just something that I like
adding in hindsight which I think for
something like that also doesn't matter
too much because generally these
buildings were not designed by their
Architects with all of the signage and
advertisements that were later placed on
them in mind so if they look tacked on
later I think that's also just going to
serve the theme that much better plus I
feel like you can always change the
ground floor of a building to your
liking at a lake at a later stage
which is something that happens very
frequently in real life as well
especially if you go to cities that are
very well known for their architecture
like Paris but basically any European
city you'll notice that some of the
ground floors are very different from
the top floors and many restaurants and
shops change them to their liking which
also to be honest isn't always to my
liking I think it's always best when a
building has a plinth that mostly fits
what the rest of the building's style is
and very typically with large commercial
stores and McDonald's and stuff like
that you'll find that they are inside an
old building which they have to protect
because it's it's a monument or whatever
but the ground floor is ruined by lots
of changes
but you know that's an opinion uh and
then everybody can have their own
opinion uh but there is this interesting
project that many uh municipalities do
in the Netherlands I don't know about
other countries but I know this is a
thing in many cities over here where uh
they Grant subsidies for restoring the
ground floors of uh shop buildings to
their original state or to fit in more
with the traditional look of the rest of
the building which I think is a very
cool project and I don't know how I
ended up on this whole tangent
um but yeah Crux of this story is I'm
going to get to signage and stuff like
that at a later stage but I think it can
safely be tacked onto these buildings
without too much of a worry for now I
just wanted to focus on fixing the big
picture and then later on seeing if any
buildings need a little sign or a cafe
name or something along those lines and
before I do that I should definitely get
some inspiration for what to call those
things because right now of the
supplement head I can't really come up
with any fun names but there really have
to be some
um there really have to be some good
examples
now of course this park is inspired by
wuhu Island but I have no idea about the
language that they speak on that island
might just be English it might just be
uh wait do do me's have their own
language did Nintendo come up with the
language for them it doesn't matter for
now I'm going for mostly a French
Colonial architecture Vibe so I feel
like French names might work out as well
but we'll see about that later right now
I am already building the floorless
coaster which is hopefully going to be
one of my new biggest money makers at
least that's when I was banking on when
I was building this coaster it also has
a huge capacity way too much for Park
attacks because you have six rows that
seat four people so that's an impressive
24 people per train I'm also going to
design this coaster in such a way that
we can run two trains so that's pretty
good which is just way too high of a
capacity for what we need in park
attacks plus unfortunately this coaster
is at the back of the park from the
entrance at least and it's not too easy
to reach through the path work so it's
not going to get too many visitors I can
already tell you that which is a little
bit unfortunate because it's the highest
capacity coaster and one that would have
earned very well if enough people wrote
this thing
um but you know what can you do
I have noticed that sometimes it's
better to build your rights with a
slightly lower capacity in architect or
at the very least not worry about your
capacity too much and I don't know what
it is about the fact that capacity in
architect is a little bit unrealistic
maybe it's just the fact that you don't
get that many guests compared to games
like Planet coaster or Roller Coaster
Tycoon which makes sense because the
guests are quite large and if you had as
many guests as you would get in Roller
Coaster Tycoon they would just be
clipping into each other the whole time
it would look weird the parts would look
overcrowded so it's just something that
would result in a very bad time so given
the art style and the skill of the game
I think it's totally understandable how
many guests go to your theme park but
capacity is something that generally you
don't have to worry about too much
unless you're building a truly low
capacity ride but it is a little bit of
a shame I think and a tiny bit of a
shame that when you build high capacity
rides like this floorless coaster and go
out of your way to give them a good
capacity with block breaks and the like
that your efforts aren't really rewarded
with much higher income
um but you know alas it is what it is
also I haven't talked about the layout
of this coaster at all but um I try to
make this as much of a Terrain
conforming coaster as possible on the
hillside over here it's a little bit
inspired by hairrazer at Ocean Park in
Hong Kong which is also very
interestingly next to the ocean on a
hill and following the terrain also has
a very interesting curved drop that I
couldn't really replicate on this
coaster but we get a slightly similar
elongated layout and the color scheme is
also a little bit inspired by it
and then at the end we have a helix that
I made extra large so we can fit this
drop tower in there and it's not the
tallest drop tower also it looks very
funny on time lapse I just now realized
I think that's part of the reason that
uh the queues don't tend to fill up that
much in architect because if you look at
the rates that they're going through
that flat ride
wow they are loading people so quickly
and it goes up super quickly it's just a
high efficiency good job guys but uh
yeah I didn't make it too tall because
otherwise it would just block the view
of the station and
I don't know that's just something that
I always keep in mind when I'm doing
observation towers and drop Towers in
this game because we have an isometric
perspective and because a very long
Tower just looks kind of weird I always
end up making those things not super
tall so yeah this thing is a little bit
short yeah what can you do about it I
think it looks better this way I could
have earned more money if I made it
taller and gave it better stats but
I just think it works like it works like
this so I'm keeping it like this also I
believe this model is based on the real
life Roto drop Towers uh by intamin
these things are some of the best drop
Towers at least in terms of their drop
if you ask me they really pull you down
you can feel the weight of that ring as
it falls down the drop I think they give
a better dropping sensation than many
other drop Towers plus you have that
rotating aspect that gives you a nice
view of the area wherever it is that you
are so yeah definitely very good drop
tower is not the top of the line I think
there are some other drop Towers which
are which do some gimmick that makes
them more interesting or are extra tall
these are never the tallest drop Towers
out there but they're just good fun
they're always good
now when it comes to drop Towers in my
head for some reason the flat ride
that's always been tied to it or I don't
know it just it fits with the drop tower
in every sense is the Top Spin and I
think the reason for that is Mel's world
and Roller Coaster Tycoon 1 where you
had a drop tower that started
underground and came out of the ground
and then you had a Top Spin right next
to it and for some reason these rides
just fit together so well and that's one
of the most memorable things I remember
from Roller Coaster Tycoon also that
whole concept of having a drop tower
start Underground and then launch into
the air is so cool and I don't think any
park in real life has done this yet and
somebody needs to get on this it's it's
just awesome just imagine walking down a
cave in the queue line and really
getting that idea of getting deeper into
the ground and then entering the the
Drop Tower and shooting into the sky
that would be absolutely really amazing
I think there are some drop towers that
kind of do that thing where you feel
like you're inside somewhere and then
the tower shoots you out of it I know
atmosphere in Lisa Berg starts within a
building so that's pretty cool it's a
good intimate drop tower as well it's
the typical Roto drop tower but yeah I
think that kind of thing is just it
hasn't been done enough especially with
the SNS slingshot drop towers that shoot
you into the sky instead of slowly
lifting you up there it just it just
seemed like a missed opportunity that
said I know in Glenwood Caverns there's
the haunted mine drop which is a drop
tower that drops you into the ground
which is also really fun and interesting
as a concept
um but you know it's it's not quite the
same so anybody with money and influence
in the theme park world please build the
kind of drop tower that we have in Mel's
World in Roller Coaster Tycoon
um that would be that would be amazing
also you can I was about to say you can
credit me for the idea baby you
absolutely you absolutely can't because
Roller Coaster Tycoon came up with it
um either I mean Chris Sawyer most
likely came up with it but it is pretty
cool
now over here I wanted to build my next
coaster because I wasn't making enough
money yet this is not because I am super
greedy because at this point I was
making enough money to sustain my Park
and keep building stuff but the goal of
this scenario is to make four thousand
dollars a month in ride ticket profits
which is huge that's a lot of money
that's definitely part of the reason why
this scenario is taking so long because
I just have to build so many rides to do
this which in a sense makes this one of
the hardest scenarios that I've played
although I'm never really struggling for
money I've almost gone bankrupt a few
times as you might have been able to
notice but it's never been a huge
struggle but definitely getting to that
four thousand dollar a month income
which is which is decently doable if you
hardly theme your rides and are mostly
just blopping down intense coasters you
can get there with a few coasters uh but
on top of that I'm trying to of course
theme this this park as much as possible
and make it kind of realistic in the
sense of the layout and everything so
it's things are taking a while it's it's
definitely uh quite difficult so we need
some coasters that are going to
sufficiently uh contribute to our
minimum of four thousand dollars of
income every month and what better
coaster to do that than the
hydraulically launched coaster the
intimate Beast which is just one of my
favorite coasters to build one of my
favorite coasters in real life as well
they're just really fun but um launched
ghosts in general are always nice to
build because you don't have to worry
about the lift Hill and especially with
this one the layouts tend to be on the
shorter side in real life as well so you
don't have to worry too much about
putting all kinds of different elements
into it
and this one has
I don't know a layouts that is basically
unlike any real life intimate
hydraulically launched coaster uh but I
think it it more or less works for for
what these things are I'm struggling
very much over here to give it uh some
area to have a decent layout before it
heads back to the station and I figured
this area on top of the staircase over
here could work out for that purpose but
it's not very easy to fit the coaster
layout in here and because of all those
challenges we also have an interesting
terrain conforming layout that starts
off with an immense dive Loop who knows
which one is which I'm beyond carrying
at this point uh and then into a large
ejector airtime Hill which looks pretty
fun I have to say it looks like it
actually gives some good air time and
then we have a station flyby which is
something that I've never seen on a
coaster like this really only wooden
coasters do this specifically a great
courses International but flybys are
awesome I think we need more station
flybys in this world
I think my voice is really breaking down
for for talking for 40 minutes straight
but uh yeah
we have a station flyby and after that
this kind of twisting layout of just a
bunch of Curves which doesn't really do
too much I imagine you get some air time
on the Twisted airtime Hill near the end
so that's pretty good but layout wise
this is this is not the best launch
coaster ever but given you know the way
that the the terrain is a challenge and
everything else I'm limited on space I
think it it does a decent bit of stuff
that is uh that is worth that it's worth
riding
plus it does remind me a little bit of
Helix and Terran especially at the
latter section where it does all of
those quick curves and quick transitions
which should probably actually be pretty
fun so yeah I guess this is a coaster
that I would like to ride in real life
which is uh one of the best ways to
figure out how you should build a layout
honestly in these kinds of games just
build something that you would want to
ride and uh of course it also has to
look good and it has to be affordable
and it has to work with the different
restrictions of the park and it has to
make money you know these are all things
that you have to keep in mind but at the
same time making something that you
would like to ride in real life I think
is always part and a very important part
of playing a theme park game like this
at least
[Music]
um I think that makes it a bit more
interesting now I've been afraid of
roller coasters for most of my life and
I've also played theme park games for
most of my life so there is definitely
just a huge part of me that appreciates
doing this stuff for the creative side
of things and for how things look and
just the fun Logistics of making it all
work out and fit but ever since I've
started riding roller coasters myself a
few years ago and started really loving
them and becoming a thrill seeker in
that sense just imagining what kind of
layouts would be fun to ride is also
part of the fun so that makes it even
better
so that is uh the top section of the
park over here we also have a top scan
flat ride because you know I figured why
not we we don't have enough flat rides
yet let's just add another one and
um I'm starting to work out a pathway
over here uh to the basically the
Mountainside where at some point in the
future we're going to get another
coaster but I'm not quite yet going to
reveal what that's going to be and in
the meantime of course there is still
some rock work and foliage to fit uh
into this area so uh putting some rocks
and some trees and some bushes in here
now my general Rook work strategy with
this area as you might have been able to
tell is to hide some of the hard Ridges
of the Hillside and make them Rocky
walls instead which is uh pretty fun to
do it's pretty easy to do and with the
way that this hill is shaped it also
gives you some fun Rocky sections kind
of snaking and coiling through the
Hillside and it also hides those hard
edges of the terraforming in architect
and make this mix this hill I feel a
little bit more natural looking and
blends everything together a little bit
so that was fun to do but also a little
bit time consuming so if you don't mind
I'm actually going to skip ahead here a
little bit and move to the next ride
that I'll be building which I think is
going to be very interesting
though before I do that I think it is
worth showcasing for a little bit how I
built the stations for these two
coasters because I didn't get to that
yet now these coasters are mostly about
the Thrills they're not really about the
theme also they're higher up the hill so
I'm not about not as concerned about the
theming here as I am at the beachfront
where I really want everything to look
very nice but at the same time I want
these station buildings to fit in with
the rest of the park in terms of the
detailing and the colors and everything
so I'm still taking some inspiration
from some other areas so for this
station building I've got the purple
border taking the purple from
basically most of the beachfront area
speaking of which I decided to put some
beach chairs and some parasols over here
as well so we get that beach look going
with a little path leading down to the
beach just for I don't know imagining
that people could go down here and
actually enjoy it but yeah the station
building is pretty simple otherwise just
some glass roof pieces and in the middle
and a simple roof like that it's
actually a little bit inspired by the
roof of python in eftling which is to me
at least that typical super simple
minimalistic thrill coaster station roof
but at the same time it it just works
it's just a shape that looks nice for
what it is and for the station of the
launched intermittent coaster over here
I decided to come up with something kind
of similar a little bit different and
still using the the same pillar pieces
and details that I use throughout the
park and I started using with basically
the first building that I ever built in
the start of the first time lapse right
next to the water side so that's
something that just keeps inspiring all
of the buildings in the rest of the park
but it helps make everything look
coherent and like everything fits
together which is a combination of some
thicker and some thinner pillar pieces
to give these pillars a sense of detail
to make them look like they really have
those Victorian decorations that you
typically see and then in the middle we
have a pointy roof and on the sides we
have some a slightly less pointy roofs
so very similar shape in general
although I did decide to make the pointy
roof stick out a bit more than the roofs
on the side and also add some awnings as
extra decoration to prevent this thing
from becoming a completely simple
standard rectangular box and now we get
to an interesting coaster that hopefully
is going to be the last coaster of this
scenario but I'm not entirely sure the
reason is that so far I've had some
months where I make two and a half
thousand dollars to even close to three
thousand dollars which is not near
enough uh to four thousand dollars to
reach the scenario also I'm not sure if
I'm going to Halt those goals for a
month or not it's all is a little bit of
a surprise once we reach the goal if
we're going to hold it for a while or
not so we'll have to see about that as
well but hopefully with this new coaster
and lots of advertising and I'm really
putting my hopes on Advertising which I
haven't done much so far because I've
had to use all of my money to buy more
land because that stuff gets really
expensive once you start buying lots of
land but yeah once everything is bought
and the rides are complete and I can
spend all of my profits on Advertising
I'm hoping that this is going to be
enough to get me over that threshold but
first
I want to finish the map I've filled in
so much of this map at this point that
the only place where I can still go is
the top of the mountain I decided to
remove the snow that I put over here
because as nice as it looks when the
scenario was just completely empty you
know I guess it gave a little bit of
interesting contrast it just doesn't
really work with the scale of this
mountain it just looks a little bit
unrealistic maybe I'll bring back the
snow as a theming elements but I highly
doubt it I think I'm just going to theme
this mine train to General Rock work and
add some tunnels and stuff like that for
sure but not really make it to Alpine
because I feel like it's just too close
to the rest of the park for that
um plus I guess there's a little bit of
a challenge here because usually mine
trains are themed to a completely fake
mountain but in this case we do have an
actual Rocky Hill over here I'm just
making a mine train on top of it and
trying to theme that so I'm gonna
somehow have to fit in some rock work
that actually does make this look a
little bit fake but at the same time
it's built on a real Hill and
all at the same time I'm also trying to
put out of my mind the fact that this is
a volcano looking at the shape of this
hill and the fact that we are on an
island over here and if you haven't
noticed it's it's it's very much a
volcano-like because we have this peak
over here with the crater in the middle
but we also have basically a Caldera a
giant dead crater in the middle of this
island
um so if we want to get to lore which I
don't have but if we want to get into
lore I I guess you could very well say
that this is an island where a very
dangerous volcano sits then exploded at
some point in the past and we're now a
little baby volcano is growing yet again
um kind of like Krakatoa or something
like that
um which makes the fact that I'm
building a coaster over here also
unrealistic but let's forget about that
because I think it would just look
really cool and maybe this is maybe this
whole island is artificial maybe that's
the lore
I don't know what the woohoo Island lore
is in Wii Sports either but it's
definitely a volcano and I'm definitely
not really sure how good of an idea it
was that they developed this whole
society on this active volcano
um but you know
that's just that's just details that I
don't want to worry about too much and
maybe I've already given it more thought
than Nintendo have at this point uh now
when it comes to the layouts of this
coaster which is uh also relevant I
would say I'm just taking some general
inspiration from mine trains like Big
Thunder Mountain mostly Big Thunder
Mountain
um but you know you always have the
classics like Expedition Everest and big
Grizzly Expedition and
um what else uh the one in Fantasia land
which looks very different but has a
really cool layout so we just do some
turns and some hills and that's about it
I decided to add two lift Hills to this
thing and then try to make my way back
to the station because that felt like
the right balance of of track to rock
work ratio not too much track and with
enough space in between to add some rock
work but you can definitely see that the
coaster is kind of snaking its way
through the entire Hill and then down
the hillside over here I wanted to add a
tunnel of sorts where it goes underneath
the path and does some kind of
interaction with that as well so it's
not just all the way out in the distance
on top of the hill and then later on
I'll figure out how to actually make it
snake back to the station as well not
entirely sure how that is going to work
out but sometimes you just have to stick
to something that looks really cool and
see how you're going to do the landing
at a later stage because it just the
layout just goes over here it just kind
of works like that it's something that
you know you can't plan everything you
just have to go with the flow of the
layouts and whatever your mind comes up
with at any stage and and hope that at
the end of the road you end up with
something halfway decent
and over here also we get some
interesting interaction where it goes
underneath the bridge and then over the
railroad and also over a future path
that I'm trying to keep in mind here
that's going to have to go underneath
the Mine Train
um so that's that and at the meantime in
the meantime I was also trying to figure
out how my railroad is going to go
around the island and this seemed like a
good opportunity to start doing that I
wanted to make sure that I finished the
coaster layout mostly before I started
doing that so I know where this real
line is going to be able to go so we
have it over here going through the back
area of the park entrance which is still
weird you know people are just endlessly
flowing out of that hotel come think of
it maybe I should add some kind of
themed way that people are arriving to
this Resort because right now there's
not a a place for cruise ships to dock
or ships in general so that's something
I still have to think about
um but yeah that is basically it for
this section of time lapse let's head
back into the game for a second and see
how it's going before I finish
everything up
all right so here we are again the park
is looking pretty good at this point I
find myself wanting to zoom in a bit
more because zooming out just makes me
realize that everything is quite huge
and it's taken so much work but you
really lose some of the detail and
really only once you zoom in well some
details obviously actually disappear
like the shadows as you can see but
generally there's just too much small
stuff everywhere in this huge map but um
I'm just gonna turn on the UI so we can
check out some rides so over here we
have the new main street-ish area with
this Main Boulevard leading up to the
train station I still want to add some
extra theming to this man actually I'm
just keeping the fence like this at the
moment but other than that this area is
entirely finished and I'm pretty happy
with it now I do like to give all of The
Coasters a POV but
um not entirely sure how much of a
difference this one is going to make but
yeah here we have the steeple chase just
making its round around the track so
quite simple trying to keep this layout
as realistic as possible which
unfortunately means that not much is
happening here there is a little bit of
banking as you can see some kind of
smooth-ish banking on some of these
turns which I think works pretty well
for this coaster type but I really
wanted to make sure that I only banked
on some of the curved sections so that
we don't have any jarring Transitions
and at the end there it does get a
little bit Speedy unfortunately it
doesn't have brakes so we really just
have to be very careful with the
momentum when building these coasters or
with our potential energy I suppose but
um
it's it's pretty fun to build these
things actually I was surprisingly
entertained by it now let's move over to
the floorless coaster I also realized I
haven't been giving my coasters names
very often I know I used to do that
quite a lot but um I don't know for some
reason I just doesn't feel too important
compared to Scenery and layout and all
of that stuff but yeah here's our hair
razor inspired Flawless coaster it
doesn't really do anything interesting
with its layouts it's definitely not the
best coaster out here in the park but I
think the layout works for the setting
and it gives it some interest
interesting interaction with the terrain
and some of the other rides as well so
I'm pretty happy with that and then we
have this launch coaster which I think
is geared to launch yeah it's a pretty
good timing some cool interaction
between these two as well so yeah for
this one as well we have a pretty simple
layout with some killer airtime I think
on that hill but other than that it's
just twisty Terran Helix esque at the
end here albeit not even quite as
powerful I think looking at some of
these transitions but I think this
little twisted airtime Hill might still
be quite good and then we go back to the
station I think one key factor that I
really like about terrain coasters is
the fact that you can raise this station
and have the layouts go down a little
bit alongside the Hillside and then you
don't have to enter the coaster or have
to enter the station with as much speed
left so it doesn't feel like you waste a
lot of speed so even though this thing
has a pretty strong layout and a pretty
strong launch at the end of the layout
you definitely have lost most of your
speed so I don't know that's just kind
of satisfying to look at a coaster like
that just slowly rolling into the
station again but yeah those are the
biggest points of interest I suppose and
then we have the railroad kind of
snaking its way through the park here
I've been using that word way too much
in this episode also I came up with a
sort of a heat like structure to make
this thing go down because the height
difference between this over here and
this station here is just way too big
and as weird as this station looks I
have been planning this station like
this for a while I just couldn't come up
with anything else these to do with this
hill plus I still needed some space to
make this path find its way back over
here
um because that felt like the right
thing to do because otherwise this would
be a complete dead end and we wouldn't
want to have that so I'm gonna try and
figure out what kind of station I can
turn this into but I think it's going to
be a pretty uh low-key one
but it might have some cool symmetry
with the pathway over here and this
building here and also as much as the
train uh has a huge route that it takes
around the island we do have two
stations I think kind of on opposite
sides of both islands and on opposite
sides of the water so I think this
station locations make sense and could
realistically be used to get to the
other side of the park-ish and then the
other side of the train is really this
this roundabout way that just takes you
through the whole park so down
underneath this section over here lots
of interaction with the coaster here
it's probably going to interact a bit
more with the Mine Train because I'm
trying to figure out how this layout is
going to go part of the reason I already
wanted to put in the train is to figure
out how this is going to interact with
the Mine Train and I think the layout
for the Mine Train is going to be easier
to make over this train than the other
way around
um but yeah other than that it just goes
all the way around the island and then
comes back here so that is basically it
for all of the rights that I've been
building so far now my last job here is
to figure out if this Mine Train
together with maybe some advertising and
stuff is enough to bring me up to a
profit of four thousand as you can see
I'm in the high 2000s right now but it's
it's not quite there yet so I'm very
curious
um if all else fails I'm just gonna have
to build another coaster and that just
means this episode is going to be that
much longer
um but we'll see anyway I'm not going to
waste any more time let's get back to
building
so my main mission for this last part of
the video was to finish the Mine Train
and we have this very typical mine
train-esque parts that's kind of more up
the hill and that's the first half of
the ride which is all cool and it's a
pretty mild ride with some rock work and
stuff like that but then I realized we
get to the second section and partly
just to fill in the entire map and find
space for this coaster to go I'm more or
less forced to go downhill a lot more
and I think this results in some fun
interaction like over here at the top of
the screen you can see the coaster go
through that tunnel and underneath the
path work and then it crosses underneath
a bridge and has some interaction with
the water over there and the train which
is all really cool but it's pretty fast
as it goes over there and then we also
have this enormous dip down to the
basically the sea where it passes by the
beach and at that point I realized after
I'd finished the coaster and did some
tests runs it reaches a max speed of 80
kilometers an hour which is kind of nuts
for any miles people in the watching
this video it's about 50 miles an hour I
I had to look this thing up but honestly
my gut feeling told me that it was about
50 miles an hour and turns out it's
almost exactly right
um but yeah it's uh it's a lot for a
mind terrain so I'm not sure how
thematically accurate this is going to
be as a family coaster I'm just gonna
let it happen because there are some
mine trains in the world that do do some
weird things I'm looking at you Fantasia
land
um and I guess it's also really fun to
have this coaster go through all of
these tunnels and have this close to the
ground action at very high speeds
um you know it doesn't do elements that
are too intense and definitely the
faster elements are quite drawn out with
very large curves and hills and the like
but it's still very intense also it took
a little bit of figuring out how this
coaster we could go to keep it as close
to the ground as possible because this
letter section over here I'm not going
to make it entirely like a real life
Mine Train would and stick it on the
ground at all times but I wanted to keep
it as close to the ground at all points
in the layout but obviously every now
and then you want your layouts to have
some hills and to have higher points and
lower points Etc
so mostly I'm just making use of the
Hillside and sticking as closely to that
as possible but using Tunnels for some
of the lower dips to make sure that the
the taller sections don't stick out too
much so we don't have huge messes of
supports anywhere which is useful
because it means that I won't have to
work too much with a lot of intricate
Rock work to hide away some of the weird
terrain bits because my strategy for
this coaster to make it really feel like
a mine train and give it that rock work
theming
was to not give the entire coaster Rock
work theming I think that would have
been way too expensive and too much
effort in a video that's already
becoming pretty lengthy
um but to try and blend The Rock work as
much as possible with the in-game
terrain especially some of the parts
where the terrain has those little Cliff
sections because they look a little bit
strange if they're paired with rock work
sometimes so I'm trying to blend them a
little bit but not place rocks
absolutely everywhere one exception was
that Cliffside uh next to the railway
tracks over there because I thought it
would be really cool to just add a bunch
of vertical looking rocks to hide that
Cliff face as much as possible the same
kind of goes for this bridge over here
where the coaster dips underneath the
path
um I think it just looks better to hide
it as much as possible but another trick
that I use to try and blend in those
rocks a little bit more with the terrain
is to paint the terrain Gray or at least
use what I believe is intended as a
concrete texture in the game to make the
Surface drain gray but it automatically
also makes the cliff texture gray which
is a handy tip if you ever want to give
a cliff texture a different color than
what's associated with the ground
texture because normally if you have a
grassy ground texture it automatically
makes the cliffs brown but as soon as
you make even one very small part of
that grid piece another color is going
to change the entire Cliff structure or
Cliff texture of that of that tile to
another texture so just by placing one
little bit of gray concrete you can make
the entire Cliff of that grassy piece
great as well and it really helps to
blend it in with the rock work and I'm
not going to do that all over the island
but definitely around the main terrain
here and wherever I'm trying to blend
these rocks with some Cliffs it's a huge
help and it works very well with a Sandy
texture as well if you want to make some
Sandstone Cliffs or something like that
something like that so
um that's a a pretty fun thing to try
also I'm going to stick to some sort of
three-line idea and only place trees up
to a certain height which means that for
most of the upper parts of the layout
this Mine Train is not going to have any
trees barely any bushes and it's mostly
just going to be gray rocks everywhere
but then as soon as you get to a lower
level and as soon as we get to the paths
and everything
I'm just going to put trees everywhere
another thing that I think was worth
pointing out is that I made this rock
work by basically taking a few Rock
pieces and making them really big and
sinking most of them into the ground so
that you get this very large Rocky
texture everywhere and you don't end up
with rock work that looks like it's made
up of many many small rocks because with
large structures like this I think it's
best to just stick with a few very large
rocks which is fun and fine because it
means that it doesn't take too much work
to make the rock work and I think it
looks pretty good but it does mean that
every single Rock You Place costs you
hundreds of dollars in in-game money
which means that you very quickly start
running out of money and I guess it
makes sense because a huge rock is much
more expensive than a small rock and
it's great that things actually scale in
terms of price as well since you can
scale all the objects in the game but
since most of the rocks are hidden and
underground and are mostly just using
the tops of those gigantic Rock pieces
to make an interesting texture
um it just means that things get really
expensive so it's good that at this
point I was making lots of money from my
ride admissions because otherwise this
whole dream would have become completely
unaffordable but it is something that's
worth pointing out and I think it's a
good reason to keep your Rook work
Ambitions to the last section of your
scenario when you already have a bunch
of rides and your Park is very well
filled out because usually only at that
point can you really afford Giant Book
Works structures
which is um something to keep in mind in
the game some things are very expensive
and some things are cheaper than you'd
expect terraforming for instance is
relatively cheap and especially if you
only change a few small things or make a
few small hills you don't pay that much
for it in fact you can generally make a
hill for less money than you can make a
giant rock for
um now moving on I wanted to theme this
area around the coaster a little bit
more
um I figured it would make sense to make
this back half of the park and I say
half but it's really just a small corner
of the park but at least make this
section in the back a little bit more
rustic so more Stone dark stone textures
a lot more wooden textures more rustic
colors and not so much the super bright
colors of everything in the front of the
park lots of trees as well so it's it's
kind of different in feel to the front
of the park which I think also matches
the fact that we're on the hillside we
don't have a view of the ocean or the
beaches we just have a small River lots
of Rook work and lots of foresty areas
so I think it goes better with the
overall Vibe of the the back half of the
park and part of that for me was also
making a covered bridge this is already
the second covered bridge in this
scenario I realized but making these
things is just too much fun and it's
really such a typical element of any
Alpine area I feel like so I figured
that was a worthwhile touch to add in
and then one of the last buildings of
this park is going to have to be the
station for the mine terrain and to be
completely honest I didn't really think
about this thing too much just like the
bridge in front of it I'm going to stick
to a very simple rustic style something
that I've done in architect many times
before so I really wanted didn't want to
give it too much thought in fact it's
mostly kind of going to be hidden among
the trees and just be a very generic
station building but I figured it would
sell the the theme of the Mind Train
best and just work for this area of the
park we don't need that fancy Victorian
whites decorated architecture everywhere
I think in a sense this building is
still inspired by the same era as the
other buildings in the park just a
little bit less expensive and a little
bit less extravagant and a bit more in
the outback if you will speaking of
which I don't think it's necessarily A
Bad Thing to go less heavy on the
details in fact looking back at this
scenario maybe I've gone too far in some
of the details especially in the front
section of the park I think it was
really fun but it's definitely not
necessary to make something nice looking
I think overall composition and use of
colors is much more important than how
many details you put into a certain
build
so I would rather focus on things like
that but it is always fun to work on
details so definitely won't stop myself
from doing that but I think detailing is
not even the most important part of what
makes a park looks good composition and
colors are 80 of the work at least and
everything else is just an added bonus
to me and I think composition and colors
accounts for everything including where
your coasters are going how your paths
are laid out how your buildings are laid
out how large they are how much work you
have everywhere what kind of color The
Rook work has and how it fits with the
terrain what kind of trees you're using
how large your trees are the color of
your trees and I think especially in
Architects where you can change the
scale of so many items and you can
change the colors of all your trees I
think these are the biggest Parts in
what makes Park work and detailing is
really just something that you notice
the more you look at a park and that
makes it more interesting to look at for
longer but to make something interesting
to look at at first glance and make it
work from the start and really the
foundation of a good looking park I
think you know it Bears no repeating but
you know just just to say it doesn't
necessarily mean that I like this area
Less in fact I think it works pretty
well with the trees and the large Rock
work and the way that we have the water
interacting with
um the bridge and the coaster and
everything
um it's just not as time consuming as
some of the other parts of the park
which have a lot more detail also
something that you might have noticed at
the top of my screen is that in fact we
do have to hold the scenario goals for
three months in a row which is quite a
challenge as you might have noticed I
found myself reaching the goals for two
months consecutively a few times
um and I think it's actually on my third
try that I finally managed to keep it
for three months usually what would
happen is that I would be almost at the
necessary four thousand dollars a month
of ride admission income or write
profits even because your admissions you
still have to deduct the costs of your
rights monthly cost from that and then
you get to your profit and you have to
have four thousand dollars of profit
every month but yeah usually every month
I found myself almost having four
thousand dollars of profit but then the
third month this would happen like a
lightning storm would happen or one of
the major coasters would break down or
people would just leave the park or my
advertisement campaign would run out and
people would start leaving the park and
no new people would enter all kinds of
stuff like that anyway it's actually
more difficult to hold these goals for
three months I found than to quickly
take them for for a month and
um yeah your your profits in one month
aren't necessarily uh a guarantee that
you're gonna keep seeing those profits
in the next few months so trying to hold
them steady was definitely a big
Challenge and looking back at this
scenario I think also the reason why
this turned out to be such a long video
because getting four thousand dollars of
profit a month wow also trying to make a
park that's not focused on roller
coasters but rather focused on this town
look and the beachfront maybe wasn't the
very best combination that said there
was an unexpected hero in this story and
that's the train line I had no idea that
this thing would even make money at all
um so imagine my shock when I realized
that this turned out to be the most
profitable ride in the whole park and
it's the last ride I built and I mostly
just built it because I thought it would
be a cool thing to add as a scenery
element and to have this thing go around
the park technically it's not the last
ride I built because I kept working on
it throughout the park but you know it's
the last ride I opened but as soon as I
did I noticed that it made a bigger
profit than all of my roller coasters so
honestly the train is the MVP of this
scenario and I wouldn't have reached the
goals of this scenario without that
without that terrain opening and
becoming as popular as it is so as much
as I expected to have to Bank off of my
coasters and use those as my primary
form of income which they are because
there are more coasters than the single
train that there is in this scenario the
train is undoubtedly the reason that I
managed to finish the scenario and if it
wasn't for that train I honestly don't
know what else I could have done to make
the scenario work without trying to jam
extra coasters or rides into places
where I wasn't thinking of placing them
so with all that said I'm just building
one little building here at the end to
finish off this corner of the park and
now let's take a look at how the park
looks in the end and how I managed to
reach the goals
all right just a little bit more
and there we go
ah so that's that that was a very long
one and honestly I'm not completely done
because I still want to showcase uh this
coaster just realized that we just
missed the boat on one of our last
trains uh finally finishing that first
long lift Hill so here we go
fun facts about block sections and stuff
I decided to give this one a weight of
uh what was it 35 seconds at least 45
seconds at most and it's uh it's
basically the perfect combination to
make sure that you never have a train
waiting on any of the lift Hills but at
the same time we can run the three
trains on this thing so in that sense
it's a pretty realistic Mine Train I
suppose
God I actually forgot that this game
actually
um makes all of the terrain transparent
when a coaster goes through the tunnel
that's very handy also I don't know
what's up with that Z fighting over
there but you guys never noticed that
also these people are in for a lot of
rain but you know it is what it is
so after that first and pretty
mild I'd say first half of the ride we
hit a short second lift Hill because
this is a Mine Train after all we need a
bunch of lift holes in these things we
also got a really cool timing on the
interaction between these trains so that
was a fun touch
um honestly I would say that was that
was not accidental but it totally was
um and then we hit this almost max speed
of almost 80 kilometers an hour and we
get some really good Air Time on there I
think and then we hit the max speed of
almost almost 80 kilometers an hour
another great airtime moments over here
this might actually be the ride with the
best air time in the park honestly and
then a bunch of tunnels down here to
make its way back to the station but
also as you can see the fact that it
hits that very high speed means that by
the time we get back to the station we
don't have to break too much so it
doesn't feel like there's a lot of
wasted kinetic energy over there so all
things considered I'm pretty happy with
this coaster and
um yeah I think it's uh it's not the
most heavily themed mine train or
anything like that but I was trying to
strike a balance between the so-called
realistic Rook work of the mountain that
we have here and just the natural
terrain but at the same time the look of
the fake rock work in a mine train
coaster and how those things are usually
themed and then of course we have the
train train which has uh different
vehicles with different colors fun fact
for people who might not know this kind
of stuff but you can color every every
single vehicle of any ride individually
so I can call it this thing I can color
this thing obviously we now lost the
cool color schemes that these things had
so I'm gonna try and bring it back to
something along the lines of what it was
but yeah I decided to give a bunch of
trains different colors there are still
a couple with the same color scheme but
um yeah we just have a bunch of
different types of trains going around
this ride so that was also pretty fun
um but yeah most of this ride is
honestly pretty boring because you don't
really see anything although I guess the
fact that it's next to the ocean and you
do have a cool view from there would
make it interesting but I think the most
interesting bits of this train are
whenever we go through an area that has
a bunch of rides that it interacts with
and maybe if you're very lucky you can
see one of these coasters and one of the
trains like over here and you have such
a cool view of that train going through
the corkscrew that's the kind of uh
thing I think dreams are made out of and
that's why you want to have different
tracks of different rides interact with
each other uh just so every now and then
the timing will just be right that you
can have some interaction with uh
between the vehicles so that's a fun
part of that I think let's see if we can
follow another train for this other
section of the ride over here
um oh that's the same train
uh like over here this one has some
interesting interaction over here with
the top scan and then it goes uh through
a tunnel here which is I believe a
decently lengthy tunnel it was a bit of
a puzzle figuring out how this was going
to fit in uh with the ride dropping down
here uh but in the end I think it works
pretty well and then you can also see
the Mine Train over here and maybe even
have a cool view of the monorail coaster
above your head
and finally we have this Helix over here
where it actually goes uh pretty quick
it's uh it's kind of dangerous it looks
looks like you might actually hit some
laterals on that one uh but yeah that's
how the the train Works in this game I
also just realized that this monorail
coaster is way too popular for its own
good
maybe we should have added some block
breaks there but you know it's too short
for that
um but yeah that is basically it for all
of the rides in this park
um so I hope you guys got a good
overview of what's available in the park
but just one last trip to every corner
we have the main first area over here
with the boulevard
with a few flat rides and the classic
Lighthouse that's been here since the
beginning and then moving over to this
section we have the largest part of the
the town well the quote-unquote town I
would say you might also notice that the
game is starting to lag a little bit
which is uh honestly just the case I
think I'm definitely pushing the
capabilities of the game engine at this
point
um but then from this large town area we
moved to the monorail coasters which are
just always fun to look at as well even
though they're not too interesting as a
coaster type I think it is fun when you
have these things dueling and it just
makes for a cute little area with a
bunch of uh I don't know just it's it's
just fun to look at these things but I
guess that goes for many coasters going
around and then we get to this crazy
mess of Tangled Trek and flat rides
everywhere
um where even these coasters have some
interesting interaction every now and
then it's just it's just too much fun to
look at stuff like this I swear it's not
just with with theme park rides I'm so
hyped when you're driving on a highway
and there's a train above you that you
cross underneath at the exact right time
it's just it's just always fun but theme
parks are the kind of setting where you
can perfectly set things up to create
these experiences in a controlled
environment you know so that's part of
the fun of games like these
um and just watching things go around is
is really important as well I think any
themed area is improved by having some
form of kinetic energy making it come to
life a little bit more and I think
that's just the fun part of watching
coaster trains and little trains go
around a park speaking of which these
trains do have comically short trains
um because they consist of only one
vehicle basically but I figured that
would be worth it because we also have
very short queue lines and
um yeah it just means we get to see lots
of little trains go around the park so
honestly I just think it's a it's a huge
plus anyway
um but yeah the last part of this park
is of course the kind of rustic uh
wooded setting over here uh but even
that I think uh doesn't stand too much
in contrast to the rest of the park and
what I'm especially happy with is
looking back at this whole build the
castle in the middle which we started
everything off with and which we can't
remove or add anything to because it's
mostly outside of Park boundaries I
think it fits in with the look of the
overall park now and it makes for a
fitting centerpiece literally and
figuratively and um yeah I'd consider it
a successful scenario not just in the
goals but also how everything ended up
as
so um let's quit this thing and see what
map we get from this
so obviously this is our trophy that
makes sense and
um just noticed the happy Co Harbor ship
over there that's a nice touch oh wait
what can I
okay maybe not doing the animation who
knows anyway our next scenario is ooh
Celeste Mountain
that's gonna be good well I guess I'll
see you guys next time I hope you
enjoyed this video and uh take care bye